[Musique]
la journée se poursuit sur tv 78 tobique
tour à saint quentin en yvelines le
festival des entrepreneurs est présent
sur le territoire pour sa dernière étape
et nous sommes dans le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
autour de moi et bien c'est un big job
dating avec des entreprises et des
demandeurs d'emploi qui viennent mais
pour trouver l'opportunité d'un côté les
recruteurs pour trouver le bon candidat
et de l'autre et bien les demandeurs
d'emploi qui viennent trouver le bon
emploi et l'une de ses entreprises qui
vient de recruter et bien et pas réglo
avec cette start up spécialisée dans
l'économie circulaire
réutilisant les déchets plastiques et
nous sommes avec la fondatrice et
dirigeante de cette pub hugo line
solaire bonjour toujours nicolas qu'est
ce qu'une start up vient recherche comme
profil sur ce genre de long ça peut être
pariez pas ce qu'on recherche des
profils qui sont assez petits copains à
6 ans de direction et commercial ça peut
être des piles plus atypiques et ça
permet justement de rendez-vous de
l'auteur de pas de croiser des gens
auraient pas forcément l'idée de
mende entretien tionnel donc la
rencontrer et qui travaille le le bois à
son compte mais pour te faire du pont
pour nous rencontrer qu'inquiéter plus
hanté commerce grands pas on peut mais
comment ces astres des embauches on sait
quand
dans les mois donc c'est pas moins fort
match
ou est-ce que vous en êtes pêche eric
neurones combien de collaborer et 12
deux embauches être et au corps trois
procès cet hiver pour enfin équipe
commerciale et communication et poux
force est tout
le broc suite
prochain oui parce que pour expliquer ce
qui rend la paix ce book c'est en fait
spécialisé la production en matériaux
comme des poules oies mais finale
exact et les
les plats les
l'inde
aujourd'hui
faute de solution cloches
matière nous il
je bois
tam en ont deux
il voulait
c'est
son destrier
blake eu vote
notre actif que
tonnes 10 l'année
les candidats
pfff
c'est bon ça déjà
faites nous
pas mal de
sionnel
et à l'invention
on attendre
non
quitterait que
euh là
bien
liang il fonctionne
pourquoi il dit
spatule
planchet
est de mouthe
et le
et besoins
critique
on a là
il est
et on
on en vit
post
peut se faire
philou
parce lui
je pose
à
pas à moi
mon nom
évidemment
ofi
ado
sasson
ça non
faute
auj
et
honduras
m
il équipe
aso
papa
hop
a sion
où
permis
et
bien
théo
j'ai
pis
perdre
alors
déjà
colas
oh
on dit
ok
faux
tu veux
c'est
vous voulez
texte
honte
non
et moi
c
m
e
poule à